what's up you guys Tuesday another
boring day in the apocrypha for Will
Smith drive by my side
just gonna add some spices yeah way from
Mathiason all the [ __ ] Mathiason what
were they called does the family to show
up from City Hall yeah I really really
wish you know I'll be out there going
shopping with the beer guys have mercy
no Mega Man if you guys haven't seen on
Mega Man the original you can streaming
off [ __ ] YouTube Charlton Heston
chested yeah Chester the chest and the
chest last man on earth
it's rusted the chest sole survivor of a
biological apocalypse create yeah living
up in his honky paradise in his mansion
playing chess with a mannequin yeah I've
got the whole thing [ __ ] secured
machine guns and spotlights and uh
there's some mutants living down at City
Hall
trying to get him because he's a relic
from the past is a good movie it is but
it's like you know what though it's like
I feel like you know other than your
[ __ ] you know classics obviously like
Dracula Frankenstein etc I feel like
[ __ ] that Richard Matheson book has
been [ __ ] adapted so like three times
like major adapted adaptations and none
of them are really that close to the
book no I mean I guess the Vincent Price
one last man on earth was pretty good
losest yeah but I mean the Omega Man the
Omega Man is a good movie but it
deviated a lot from the text and the one
the recent one the Will Smith one does
yeah that kind of thought don't terribly
cuz and the ending was completely yeah
it was completely negated the whole
point
yeah of the [ __ ] story and what what
made s story good were the the mutants
have talked yeah you know what I mean
without talking mutants II don't have a
movie and it was a global pandemic but
you know there weren't wasn't many
people that had survived and without
that you don't have the movie the Will
Smith version it was just New York
that's right so it's another dumb
[ __ ] is that
shoulda been the entire Earth well yes
the last man on earth the Omega man yes
sorry
well notes in the whole point of the
story and the reason it's called I am
Legend and it's stupid because he's a
legend to the damn zombies yeah because
he goes around killing them in their
sleep yeah they're not zombie said then
yeah he's he's the monster right that's
like the whole point of this whole point
of the book and in the movie the movie
Omega man who's from what 67 maybe early
7 is [ __ ] awesome it is I love that
movie yeah sure Cheston plays a guy
called Neville car I think it's Colonel
Neville and he was a scientist and he
was a biochemist I guess and he made a
dam by a weapon that got out and it
killed almost everybody except some
people mutated into these psychopathic
psychopathic turned them into what do
you call them albinos
yeah and they had their own religion
they were trying to go back to the damn
medieval era they were just you know
like work yeah they ran around all day
burning up burning down all modern
knowledge because they blamed that they
were post apocalyptic you know they
didn't like anything that was modern
yeah never was look tough yeah and then
Neville was the last modern thing he had
to go well he wasn't gonna give in to
him anyway he was uh running around he
spent most of time jogging dear today
running around in his [ __ ]
convertible Ford Mustang and he had a
damn Smith & Wesson MK 760 submachine
got to be shooting at him they couldn't
come out during the day yeah they were
like vampires but he'd lose track of
time he'd go watch a movie and he goes
oh Sh it's getting dark you know
although you think that like you get you
would know he was remember he was
getting kind of high drinking and [ __ ]
true and I guess after a while he
watched the same movie so many times
that he just you know he was going crazy
yeah I guess and uh something bit you
know how they got guys that they have it
a whole little hobby of making dolls
from movies yeah and I saw somebody made
a Neville doll that looked [ __ ] Osso
that's right it was it was about twelve
inches tall
and he could buy a Charlton Heston head
and then made that whole Air Force
uniform with the machine gun and the
[ __ ] uh the flight suit and the and
the colonel hat and everything revenue
is yes at the end when he was going on
his damn suicide mission to find a while
you know instead I was laughing at your
yeah yeah it looks like your hose in the
front those on the wall down what was
cool is that in that particular movie
almost was an action movie almost they
didn't quite have the action movie
theory down in 71 not as well had that
been made a few years later it would
have been even better I think there
would have been more shooting and stuff
more stunts yeah it was good like I said
they made the Will Smith one and it was
just well that is nine late that was
2000 so I think it just made me so mad
because I heard that they were doing
another adaptation I said oh maybe
they'll actually like do it like the
book this time because that would be
cool because they haven't done that yet
but they they just made it essentially
like a zombie slash vampire movie at the
end of the world not even it was just
like the end of the city which is dumb
somehow and somehow in a Mega Man they
were able to film places in downtown LA
and it was empty when the Sun was up I
don't understand how they did that well
I was looking that up because they've
done it for some others like in 28 days
later they got like some amazing shots
of like London with nobody and it was
just like what how they do it and I'm I
don't even [ __ ] know still but it's
like you look the [ __ ] up and it's like
oh well yeah they they would shoot it
for like you know ten minutes at a time
or something they block some streets off
and then they can only shoot for ten
minutes I'm like but still you would
think that in the background you would
see at least one [ __ ] person that
wasn't like didn't get the memo or
didn't want to play along going hey I'm
in a movie you know even though there's
everything else supposed to be alive
here I'm not Cheston was running around
in that damn Mustang and wrecked it and
[ __ ] I mean you should be able to see
cars [ __ ] up in the skyscrapers and
stuff and it looked real not skyscrapers
but you know yeah 20 still 20 storey
buildings is shooting at him I'm always
kind of like a maze
because there's a lot of movies like
post-apocalyptic type of movies that you
know that that shoot in like an the
actual city and it's just like totally
empty and I'm like can you imagine the
logistics of having to film and like you
can't there's like can't be a single car
there can't be a single person there
can't be anything like nowadays it's
easier because you can just digitally
wipe that [ __ ] out but back in the old
days you had to really do that for real
unless you I guess you could like kind
of build like a set and then just do
like a matte painting I guess but that
you know depending on how good the matte
painting was I don't know like how
feasible that kind of [ __ ] is although I
have been surprised like some older
movies that did that that like I
couldn't believe like how realistic the
matte pays you know what I didn't
realize the [ __ ] the John Carpenter
movie the thing a lot of that was matte
paintings yeah a lot of the snow was and
I could not yeah like when I saw the
behind the scenes stuff and they're like
yeah we just put this snow like in this
like one [ __ ] hundred foot area and
that everything else is just like but
I'm like holy [ __ ] crap I never would
have guessed yeah the whole worthy where
they got the alien of yam was Matt got a
painting of a hole they were just
looking like that is weird did a good
job yeah I would I would never have
guessed that in a million years well
like I said there was a [ __ ] art to
it yeah I mean you know the best matte
painting is so you don't know that
they're matte painting they did they did
fill most of it in a snowy environment
that they are to get that damn breath it
did look cold
yeah that's the good thing about that
yes it's like in that 28 days letter
later one isn't it isn't what the
vampires that we're never what was it
was that one called with the vampires
that we're up thirty days thirty thirty
days a night it didn't look cold to me
yeah that was another one that like a
lot of it was yeah set and then like a
lot of it was fake snow and like a it's
just hard to it's hard to fake those
little details about a cold environment
like little bits of frost here and there
and the breath and the way glass looks
when it gets real cool it's like even
when they CGI it it does it just doesn't
quite right like CGI and people move
differently when it's [ __ ] cold yeah
it's just doesn't matter
all your joints are like for you but
then you look at you look at Jeremiah
Johnson with Robert
you can tell if that was done in the
[ __ ] cold you can tell that he was
that he was trying to catch a fish but
with his bare hands and a frozen [ __ ]
river it just looked [ __ ] cold yeah
well just like the bedroom and the
Exorcist
yeah and they were doing the exorcism
they just made it like they shot that
inside a freezer yeah
just so everyone would be like super
cold right began so since we were
talking about like book adaptations I
was for some reason every now and then I
get like a weird like hair across my ass
or whatever and I have quit has it had
to look some [ __ ] up to him yeah I
wouldn't allow it to grow that it's it's
a metaphor yeah so yeah so I was
thinking earlier that there I might have
mentioned this on one of the shows
before or something like that like this
really good like short story that I like
called the triumph of death which is
from one of those Alfred Hitchcock
anthologies with which I think I brought
up yesterday they did before and I've
always wanted to see like a movie
adaptation of that and I'm kind of
waiting for it to go into the public
domain so like I can write a screenplay
and see if it gets me because I think
it'd be like really creepy but then I
found out that like apparently and if
any of you in the UK remember this or
know where I can get hold of it cuz I
don't know if these episodes even exist
anywhere you mark but there used to be
like I think it was called a late night
horror it was like an anthology series
like in the UK and they did an
adaptation of this story I think [ __ ]
Claire Bloom was in it she was in
[ __ ] well she was in a lot of stuff
but I remember her from Clash the
tightness but yeah so she was in it and
I'm like man I got to see this so I've
been like looking everywhere and I can't
[ __ ] find it the only thing that I
can find from that old TV show is just
like a little snippet of like the
opening credits or something like that
so it's like so this was like a 6
episode like horror anthology series
from the UK and now it's like completely
gone like nobody's saved it that makes
me really really sad I mean I'm not you
know I don't know like how good this
adaptation would have been but it's like
I really really would like to see like a
film adaptation existing more of this I
guess not like I can't find it I mean
I'm sure somebody must have kept it or
if somebody's got it somebody has to but
maybe it was it was before VHS maybe
right but it's like I'd love to see it I
mean I'd really love to see like a big
screen adaptation of this story because
it's so it always like creeped me out so
much it's just like this [ __ ] creepy
old lady and she lives in this creepy
old house and she has this um like a
companion she's like her housekeeper
slash cook slash she reads to her and
[ __ ] like that like you know rich old
ladies used to have and the the thing
that really like attracted me to this
story was that the house is clearly
haunted but the old lady is so evil that
she pretends that it's not so that all
of her companions go batshit crazy hmm
it's like it's like gasps lady told me
about this yeah it's so so good it's
like and it was one of my ah you know I
used to read like all this like um
Alfred Hitchcock anthologies and stuff
like that when I was growing up and that
story like really really stood out to me
it's by H Russell Wakefield and it's
like he's apparently he he was like a
really big deal like he's a one of
Britain's preeminent to ghost story
writers from back in the day and I've
read a couple of those other stories too
which are also good but I haven't liked
any of them as much as this and I really
really think that this would make a
[ __ ] great movie like I think it
would be really really creepy and I wish
somebody would [ __ ] do it another
thing I was thinking about today just
randomly because I was thinking about
books and book adaptations does anybody
that grew up in the 70s remember that
there was a show on PBS called I think
it was called book bird or
cover-to-cover
or maybe there was two versions of the
same show and it's this guy and his name
was John Robbins I think and he would
pick that was like one book or sometimes
I think there was two like on per
episode and he would they would read
like parts of the books they were
usually like ye
type books you know particularly big
ones that came out in the 70s like the
sea egg and like the westin game and
stuff Arnold st. Weston game was on
there but maybe figs and phantoms was
that Ellen Raskin and and he would draw
like scenes it was kind of like Bob Ross
but with y-a novels he wasn't doing
paintings he was just like charcoal
drawings and like white fit and
was like a really really good artist and
he would just like draw these scenes
like while someone was reading like
passages from the book and I used to
[ __ ] love that show I found like two
or three episodes of it on YouTube but
the weird thing is that I looked it up
on Wikipedia because I was like I
remember seeing like a whole bunch of
books because I was talking to somebody
on in the YouTube comments the other day
about Zilpha Keely Snyder that writer
and how much I loved the headless Cupid
and that was where I first heard about
that book was on his show like cuz I
remember the drawings that he did and
everything like that but then when I
looked at i'ma wikipedia the episode
guide for that show it's like doesn't
say that that book was on there and I'm
like did I just imagine my whole entire
[ __ ] childhood because I'm pretty
[ __ ] sure that that's where I found
that like I saw that book on that show
I'm like wow that sounds kick-ass I'm
gonna go to the library and get that
because it sounded like exactly my kind
of thing because it was all like
witchcraft and [ __ ] so uh so I don't
know it's really weird so I don't know
if anybody has any of those I saw a
couple of them like that somebody posted
on YouTube but there's only like a
couple of them on there and none of them
are ones that I really remember except
maybe Bridge to Terabithia
I remember that episode but I don't know
it's just like really weird and it's
really weird how all of this stuff like
from our childhood even though it wasn't
even that long ago
it's like if you cuz no you didn't have
a VHS back then you know I'm a VHS and
the [ __ ] seventies if nobody taped it
and if the you know PBS didn't keep you
know the tapes or anything like that
then it's [ __ ] gone yeah and you
never be able to see it again well it
makes sense to me most of Elvira's
you're not Elvira but most of Vampira is
gone yeah like only a few seconds of
that's left isn't that shitty there was
a lot of those daytime hosts or the
hosts of like the [ __ ] yeah or host a
lot of it's gone they had one from the
Michigan area outside Detroit that my
buddy Eric used to tell me about he's
called the ghoul yeah I think we made a
suicide he was like some weird dude who
was actually you know and he was making
that [ __ ] up as he was going I heard
that he committed he think he thought
that the dude had committed suicide yeah
it'd be doing weird [ __ ] like set
himself on fire on the show and I don't
know it does he and every only nothing
him survived
does anybody remember him yeah that's
the thing because pretty much every like
major city had their [ __ ] own horror oh
yeah and only like a few of them got
really popular like I'll fire Zach early
you know some people like that that got
really popular it's probably some of
their stuff survive just because people
remembered them more yeah but every
major like city had their own yeah
evidently the Google started losing his
[ __ ] yeah all right as he was doing
being the host and they took the show
from him and I think he killed it was
just going crazy
yeah he was just doing doing crazy and
crazier [ __ ] and he was kind of like
recording himself outside doing this
stuff you know said please love me quick
no I don't think that's how it went
that's crazy that's not how it went it
was just I don't remember he just said
that you know I don't remember all the
details I just remember him telling me
about it yeah you know but brought up
with this guy called the Gould he would
wear his long trench coats and I think
he had a beard and like I think he was
said he was bald I've never seen the guy
huh kind of like an Uncle Fester tie oh
I'm gonna look that it's kind of like an
Uncle Fester type dude and he got more
and more bizarre on the show and
evidently they took the show from him
and he Denny I think he killed himself
that's how I remembered it huh may not
be true but I think that's what he told
me and this was in Michigan in Michigan
I'm a Detroit area that would a vision
because some people are really into like
all this old horror hosts and stuff like
that what it's interesting because I was
watching like [ __ ] episode of one of
the cinemassacre shows the other day and
he was going into like this whole
history of some [ __ ] that I didn't
really know hardly anything about like
all the old spook shows from back like
in the old days of like movie theaters
where you would go and it'd be like a
double feature of like horror movies and
then they would do like like [ __ ] in the
theater like there'd be a stage and
they'd have like magic shows they'd have
like a blackout you know what I mean
Laura all the lights would go out and
like they do like all these little
pranks and [ __ ] like that
hmm and then they had they actually had
like some of them actually had like
famous people like turned like you know
at past their heyday like Bela Lugosi
and stuff but it's like they would make
appearances like in the costume and all
that other kind of [ __ ] and I was
wow that's like something my hadn't
really I didn't know that much about
like I knew about like all the William
Castle like all the gimmicks they used
to do like the tangler and all that kind
of [ __ ] yeah but I didn't know they used
to do like the live-action type of stuff
where they turn all the lights out and
the place and they would have like magic
shows and like [ __ ] skeletons and
celebrities and all that kind of [ __ ]
sounded reasonable yeah so it's like a
vaudeville show yes it was like really
cool it was and it was cool he did like
a [ __ ] it was like a 30 or 45 minute
that on cinemassacre he was like talking
all about the history cuz he had just
got a book about it and he got really
interested so he did like a show about
it so there's a lot of stuff that's lost
and will never be found
I mean nas ferrata was almost lost yeah
I think they saved one copy
yeah it's order destroyed yep but they
saved one copy and it leaked yeah cuz I
the copyright yeah but that that's the
thing like I really I really like likes
I old silent horror movies and it's like
amazing how many of them are lost and
like some of them they only know of them
cuz like only a few minutes of it
survived and titles like I was watching
this one the other day it was Russian
actually and it was pretty creepy it was
called I think it was called the
portrait and I think it was initially an
hour long or something but only eight
minutes of it survived like only between
six and eight minutes of it well there
was that show that we did about you know
the I having a terrible loss of life day
and that lost library or the idea of it
is based upon a list of book titles
classic books that go back 2,000 years
to the Roman era sometimes sometimes and
we have the the list of the titles of
those books but but not that but not the
books and some of those guys some eases
stories are just dying to get their
hands on those books but yes there's any
left I mean yeah they just can't find
him
old Roman history books gone stuff like
that it's like it's it's kind of sad
when you think about I mean it's
understandable because there's so many
people and so many things and so many
situations and you know there's Wars and
yeah fires fires and all kind of [ __ ]
and it's like if you don't flood I mean
probably better now because anybody
uploads everything to the cloud but even
then it's like we had an EMP aerilon
Center the aliens come in zap us it's
like we're looking a
well yeah if you have people you know
people would believe a lot in technology
especially these young people that grew
up in an era of [ __ ] you know the
internet and just they just put
everything you know that all their hopes
ended into the Internet
back in the 1800's there was an EMP was
so bad if I could fried out telegraph
wires yeah and they think that happens
every couple centuries and the world we
live in now is not EMP proof if that EMP
happened again it came from it was a
solar flare that did it I believe yeah I
gotta watch them Solar and if there are
gamma bursts or something like that I
think a gamma-ray burst kills everything
yeah it's a big dose of radiation it
would destroy everything but I think it
was a solar flare if we have another one
of those solar flares it'll put us back
down back to the 1900s
that's another cheerful thing I think
about in the middle of a panda you heard
about all this pandemic [ __ ] solar flare
Dubai like I said you can't it's it's
kind of like worrying about like an
asteroid hitting the earth and what it's
like yes it could happen but I don't
know it's just one of those things it's
like you can't do anything about it you
need to they need to hire harden our
electrical infrastructure goes out yeah
that would definitely be they are trying
to put a bill forth to do that to make
us EMP proof they should do it yeah that
does seem like a pretty high priority
right it's protect all these databases
and stuff yeah because it's like your
car your cars and your laptops won't
survive but you can just buy a new one
as long as you still got power to make
everything yeah that's what they need to
do yeah so you know you think about that
it's like you're bummed out about the
pandemic hey think about it yeah it's
not [ __ ] compared with that EMP a
natural EMP from a solar flare would
have been a lot worse than this flu
that's true yeah all right so you done
yet all right so have a good rest of
your Tuesday and as usual we'll be back
to give you another update and another
[ __ ] rambling discussion against
remarkable